hi everyone it's jerry i am going to hop
into an hourly rapid arena a bit of a
late start
should get in
about five games
time controls are ten plus
zero
so
no increment
have to be on top of the time
which is
a bit of an adjustment
any moment now hopefully there we go
malone bh
let's start
i guess with e4
all right carol khan
i guess we'll go for two nights
all right a6 is not so common
what's the idea there
not quite sure what the idea behind a6
is thinking about one of these two i may
this might be an opportunity to
not allow this guy to develop so easily
i'll i'll go for this
i think the computer would probably say
put your pawn in the center and don't be
don't be
concerned about a pin
structure can still change yeah
so i'm gonna go
towards the king side
i wasn't really too concerned about that
move
and this guy needs to move again i think
i want to have a setup where this guy on
f1 is out and about
so
let's put this guy here
we're here
all right let's go here
it could be a little annoying when the
bishop is on this square
that can be a bit of a bug
let's start with this
because when i play here i don't want to
have to deal with b5 so
all right well this guy is uh
i don't have to worry about the bishop
putting pressure on my knight at least
so let's go here now ideally
i think i would like to have
the f file open up
and then i'm immediately coordinating on
f7
so that's uh there could be some nice
tactics that fall in my favor
when uh
my pieces begin to intersect
so let's start here
sensible
dark square bishop has to play
center supported
and i don't think i really ever want to
castle queenside so
should i consider this right now
oh
you know what i could have considered
something other than this move
i think a quick attack against this was
there
okay i might have i might have missed
that
that was uh maybe
too uh
yeah not thinking forward enough just
then
too fixated on the
the standard stuff
missed a quick strike there pretty sure
especially with this guy here
you know this diagonal is much more
weakened okay
i missed my chance
now how do i want to approach this
i run to some tactics if i try this move
maybe i could start with this one so
that when i play knight h4 there isn't
this anyone this anymore because i have
the clean up to defend
all right i think now i want to go for
this one
also with the knight no longer on this
square i could have considered a5
okay that's that's pretty interesting
so black is okay with these double
isolated pawns
i do see the benefit
yeah for sure there's a nice control
over this square
i think what i'm going to do
is take a timeout
and clamp down on this structure
i may end up losing a pawn
this knight could return i i see this
move
to defend if there's another one i guess
i could still defend
okay
so i wasn't i was intending to simply
defend the pawn
also i didn't point it out yet but i
have dreams of maybe putting my knight
on d3 now that this square has opened up
i didn't quite have time for uh
you know i couldn't really get these two
moves in b3 and a
a5
i thought it better to to get in this
clamping down type move
so now this situation here what do i
want to do
don't really want to take the knight i
don't think because then this guy is
pretty silly
hmm
i want to get a knight here on d3
uh
hmm maybe i need to take this night yeah
let's take the night
how to approach this now this guy's
clumsy
maybe
maybe this maneuver this guy's playing
very fast
maybe maybe i could start with pinning
the knight let me let me try pinning the
knight
i don't know if i'm really getting a
you know i don't think i'm getting it
anywhere fast here with this move i
don't think a whole lot is is
accomplished with that move but
all right
how about we start with this one
i have to just i have to watch out some
okay continues to play fast
to watch out that uh
don't fall too far behind on the clock i
was also going to say my bishop on this
square was unprotected so it may have
been tactically vulnerable
okay
maybe now i go for a maneuver
is this too far-fetched
this is the dream square for the night
i guess i go for this
one two three four or one two three four
wait i'm miss counting here
one two three
one two three
okay
i'm going to go with this
in the end my queen is here
and i'm going to go here
i like that uh along this journey yeah
okay
along this journey my knight could end
up on this square
it's a healthy square i am prepared also
with the sequence to
to give up
i'll hang on for a second
losing my train of thought this guy's
playing so fast
let's start with this
okay let's go here
i'm anticipating some pressure here
so
this is
not just some
thread against the rook uh it's aimed at
controlling that f6 square
let's put this guy here
if bishop there i think i need to
duck that exchange i i i don't believe i
can afford
um
i i don't think i could allow this
knight to get to f4 and sit there for
even a move
you giving me that
um i don't know if i want it
i have to accept that though
i have to accept that and then
and then just
try to
i don't know hold on to my center some
so
i'm giving greater weight to stopping
knight f4 rather than securing e4 here i
could get pushed
around okay let's start with this one
oh wait this pawn is hanging
i should probably take it
yeah let's take it
let's take there
and maybe i could uh go here next
i don't have to
could fall back still
yeah i think i should fall back
now there'll be a sacrifice here all
right let's try it for i'm weaking my
positions
a real lot right now
also i was not able to take in that
position with my queen she has
responsibility
opponent continues to
fire away
okay
suppose i take
i do have these jumps covered
i think i want to get this rook off
as soon as possible
something better i only have two minutes
this will go with this
recapturing with the the king okay
they want to take with the rook
now
yeah let's go here
now i'm in a spot to recapture my queen
queen was cut off from defending g3
there
i still am off the exchange there is no
move here my knight's covering that i
have some check
maybe if this queen goes too far
this knight's unprotected
i'd really like to drive it back
not with the pawn
but with the queen on one of these two
this is the more active
why not try and plant the queen right
here
yeah let's go for this
queen right here
seems sensible
right here i have this
let's make a fast move
like to get rid of the knight and the
queen i'm pretty much welcome to every
every exchange here
so i i do have some check
i i could have i should have maybe
started with that one
right let's put this one in real quick
okay
repeat
i have a fork if
opponent is not careful
not sure how to improve here let's start
with this one do i have to do anything
real quick
this check is not quite working
if the okay
all right this is my moment to get my
rook to a better spot
or there's gonna be night here
why am i so down on time
let's try this get the queen here
guess we're gonna take a pawn
in there
this one
yep i have this pin 44 seconds
all right i'm gonna go here
this uh check right here is scaring me
tricky night
so dangerous
i think i could do this step up and
defend my queen if there
opponent continues to fly
okay
get the queen off 25 seconds
oh the knight's dead
oh it could have went there
all right
should be able to convert this one this
one was tough um
just didn't have any time to
kind of
share share my thoughts
king has one square
he's boxed out
yeah let's cut him off
they're always tricky tricky opponents
to
play against i did have mate
with the with the queen instead of
getting another queen
all right
speed
speed player
uh i don't think i played that one so
well
um
yeah i'm already thinking right out of
the opening there
i should have played
d4 instead of h3
just put another pawn in the center next
time
okay
let's see who we get 193 are in there
not really
expecting to take
any great top position in this
tournament
just trying to play some quality games
all right
next up
let's go for
sicilian i guess
okay
so is this a
hint that there's a closed sicilian on
the way
probably not now
the knight on f3
alright let's go here
making many pawn moves early on
this secures queen post on c7
and prepares to expand
not that i'm ready to play that straight
away
just a couple notes
behind a6
put the queen here
eyeing up an e5 move
or i should say preventing e5
so this is
it's interesting how a6 is providing
security for my queen to get to c7 and
my queen is providing security for my
king knight to get to f6 without fear of
this
cuts out that
cuts out this
all right this guy's now unprotected
do i want to play that straight away i
guess so
or i could maybe go for this maneuver
knight here and then fall back
and not go for a knight exchange
i'll i'll go for this
and prepare to enter a different
structure
this one
where now i'm gearing up for d5
i'm
i have to be a bit careful here
okay it could be the case i end up with
double def pawns
um
how so well if this move and then here
and then here
when i go here bishop takes if i take
with the bishop there's this one
so
i have to be careful
i have to know that yeah we are going
straight for this line here
this one i have to take with the pawn
take with this it's a true pin on the e6
pawn
so not the most common structure around
uh i'm not really seeing some great
attack against my king
he might just be
quite all right hanging out on the
king's side on f8 i certainly don't want
to castle here
also
if i put my bishop here there's rook
takes pawn
maybe this wasn't such a wise choice
do i have to go here and then here
feels very slow
all right let's go here
where's my development
i don't have any development
got a king who just doesn't know where
he belongs
opponent is
centralizing
don't hurt me
am i now close to getting a developing
move in
i could also think about trying to
exchange queens
oh you know what instead of this move i
could have maybe considered that one
queen on f4 stops queen h6 this was one
of
this was i think the primary thought i
had
okay and so much for queen on f4
uh i have this move though the rook
isn't defending that square anymore
maybe this isn't a
a nice a nice moment to transition
towards the king
side ah for queen exchange
i'll go for that
yeah it's starting to
have to be careful here
underdeveloped it only takes one slip
and you can be
toast
oh
well i think this immediately shifts the
evaluation in my favor
these guys right here while
really well centralized uh
i have a
pretty pretty secure
uh pawn presence in the center
a little concerned about my mouse
i've been doing some weird things here
all right
hope it doesn't die on me
all right how do i want to approach this
i have the bishop hair and a beefy
center
this is strictly preventative
oh i i was threatening to win the bishop
so it is producing a square on c2
how to approach this
i mean i could even invite
this guy up to f5
hmm
thinking of moving one of my h-pawns not
sure which one is best
um i think i want to maybe go with this
guy
yeah let's go with this guy
why of all moves this one
in anticipation of this i could kick it
i'm looking at a forward knight move i
also
i'm securing this square similar to h6
was stopping queen h6 h5 is stopping a
knight
jump into h5 i'm defending h5 by putting
my pawn here
defending h6 by putting my pawn on h6
i think i want to continue
pushing some pawnees or maybe maybe this
move right now
yeah let's go with this one
i'm doing this because i don't want to
see this construction where the bishop
sees outside of the chain
so i was thinking this it would block
the bishop or
i guess now in this case with the bishop
on this square
i'm not able to see
v2 but now this guy is pinned to the b2
pawn so i could try and
scare it away
with this
with this advance
um
yeah let's go for this one
the idea
coming up bishop d7 and day four
night here straight away i give it a
kick
it goes back
and
how to defend the pawn with the pawn
with the bishop
okay
let's go here
let's go here
to be careful
my bishop is now unprotected so there
are some
three pieces for a pawn scenario
but
i think i'd be getting this guy in the
end this is this guy right here i'm
viewing as a two-point pawn without this
guy it's super weakening now to the
king's side
how to defend
this guy
i think i may want to just go with the
pawn
as odd as that looks
i mean i could consider that
bishop g5
and then this
then i'll go here i'm anticipating this
i want to have this square still covered
uh
also if i play here and this pawn is
still in its home square there's
the idea may be to try and break up my
center
um
i was just thinking for a second this
move i could play here
yeah some sacrifice here isn't the
greatest for white okay
maybe i push this guy further
yeah why not
maybe uh
maybe even go another step
okay
now right about now what do i want now
right about now what do i want to do
well this knight is restricted oh wait a
second
let's see here
rook takes here
that would be sneaky
yeah maybe i should do that
yeah i'm gonna
yeah some sacrifice here let me put this
bishop on a what at least feels like a
much more secure square
is bothering me that it's unprotected
uh it's also
indirectly hitting here maybe i could
look to try and converge on
g2
it's like in the first game i was
pointing out converging on f7
we could get these uh these two pieces
working together
i'd like to have my king on f6 one day
so i think this would be healthy ideally
a dark square
all right
step up with the kingy
yeah let's step up one
and that one
maybe go up again
yeah let's let's let's go let's start
let's start moving
the pawns
off of my dark squares
ideally in this situation i think it
i do well to have my pawns on light
or
maybe better stated i do well to
coordinate my structure with my
unopposed
bishop
and that guy's the dark square bishop in
this case
and you put the pawns on light we can
expect at some point maybe a light
square bishop exchange and then this guy
ties in really well with the
with the more simplified position
what the
with the structure
both under five
i have a much easier time ahead of me
here
it's not so clear where this guy's home
is
no no great outpost
yeah my my my mouse keeps uh
locking up some i'm not sure what's
going on that could really uh
that could really end up hurting me
in time scrambles so
yeah i'm just saying now i'm giving my
opponent an opportunity to coordinate on
this b5 square
bishop here
i guess i could
i could challenge
instead of the king here i'm looking at
the bishop on the long diagonal rarely
will that be a bad
rarely will that be a bad thing so also
maybe i could get in this move i could
play right now
and follow up and win the exchange
yeah let's
or let's do it like this maybe
let's start with this one
maybe get these two moves in i think
i think it's
close to the case where my opponent has
to give up the exchange
this pawn is probably going to end up
being too much
if if i'm allowed to
have a connected pass pawn
f4 e3 construction
that uh not seeing how that could be
that could be so good
at the same time
let's not rush with moving that pawn
let's get this guy here let's put some
pressure on the dark squares
since the color complex uh
white will find it most difficult to
defend
my mouse is once more worrying me
okay chopperoni
take towards the center
okay
i may have to do something with my mouse
i don't think it's dying on me
so there are some
some tricks here
all right i am back
and
what am i trying to do here
well i had some
some issue i was trying to sort out
there with my mouse
now i'm down on time
should be winning a pawn
my bishop was on this square
you know there'd be some trick where you
take on c3 and then on this square
so i really have a great decision here
wow
going into the pin
so now the knight's hanging in the
there's still this pin here
i don't think they could get out of it
okay i guess i'll take another pawn
if my rick wasn't attacked i would be
thinking about playing here
i'll take the exchange
let's let's go like this
let's go here
maybe would have been better to get rid
of the tricky knight first
let's do it like this though i could
consider going for mate
the real thread here is this one like if
the knight moves well where does the
knight move
well let's go here
37 seconds
these two coming up
can't quite get to the uh
oh do i have to watch out for stalemates
yeah they can't get it can't quite get
rid of the knight
forcefully
so
some trick here here and then knight
here
i don't take with the rook
could do some other move like i could
take with one of these two threatening
me one now
there is that move okay they resigned
all right
next up
cosmic chess
yeah i have to i have to play faster
it's going to be tough
i can't move as fast
while my mouse is charging
[Laughter]
maybe if i could get through this game
right here then i could uh
have a
much more reliable
speedy mouse but right now
things are a little bit different for me
we have a carol khan
coming up next to a bishop g5
knight f3
chaparroni
i guess bishop f4 is a move
we'll see i'll chop straight away
not much choice
all right my knight is pinned
all right this early pressure on my
queen night makes me think that it's
gonna be
especially difficult to try and get this
guy out and about
and only then play e6 so
i think i have to play e6 straight away
okay piling up the pressure
don't have much choice here
bishop d7 yeah i guess so
okay well after h6 the bishop has to
retreat
or take my knight
i think it's worthwhile to flick this in
straight away
try and
get some clarity here
show me your hand
bishop here i could track down the light
square bishop so
if the bishop fell back there i could
could have considered
playing what
um
some night move here
maybe maybe maybe i could have gone for
an exchange
and then knight here
and then capturing away on this square
maybe maybe we
would have both knights and the light
square bishops off the queens eventually
exchanged
and i would enter a good versus bad
bishop symmetrical structure ending
anyhow
here we are
unopposed light square bishop
i think we'll be playing within the
structure in this
game if i take here
i'm ready to destroy the king side
structure
so that means the queen would have to
recapture but then this bishop would
have
we'll have a
a home
a home on d5 for what seems like forever
i'm gonna start with this
open this guy's eyes straight away
may feel a little uncomfortable to put
the queen and king on the same diagonal
but i think it's necessary i thought it
was necessary
so we enter a new phase now the new
structure
i think i should chop that knight
and
what
yeah let's uh
and give the bishop pair back put the
queen right in the center right now
i could still look forward to uh
i mean we're almost there
you know i was expressing earlier
exchanging both nights
the light square bishop
in queens queen here i think soon needs
to be challenged
queen here queen here
and then f5 chop chop
i'm the one playing for a win there
king i'll camp out on d7
where do i try and still keep the queens
on
seeing is how this king is uh probably
not going to feel so comfortable or
maybe we begin with a
a move like this
not yet show my hand with this queen
yeah
oh i'm just saying now i'm threatening
queen takes d4
i was uh i was fixated on
some bishop move and that may be
that may be a thing as well
there the check i'm not too concerned
about
i would uh i would prefer to not
have the queens i would prefer not to
have a queen
i prefer this position right here with
my pawn on e6 rather than d5
so now
step one is what
i'd like to get these two moves in
if i play b5 straight away i think this
is hitting
so this one
and then there so maybe i should play
this
not only threatening a fork but stopping
this pawn from moving so let's see b5
i'm sorry
bishop here
right there
b5
rook here
and then i fall back
the rook is a little awkwardly placed
a4 could still hit but then i could take
i'd have a passer
i'm gonna go with that
it's more positional idea than anything
there just happens to be a tactical idea
as well
i don't want this guy to be traded off
so easily i don't want this rook to
become activated along the a file so
easily
ideally i want to go hunting for the
a-pawn
like this pivoting about on the light
squares b5 makes a lot of sense
controlling these pawns from advancing
not too concerned about that move
i weaken my dark squares but it's not
like i'm castled and i'm gonna be
getting mated on g7 or anything
let's put this guy here
light and dark
healthier structure is the main thing
giving this uh position a quick glance
it's probably
i think that's the first thing that
sticks out to me
at some point i could grab a tempo
against the pawn so if challenged
white may need to tend to that
pretty important pawn
my h-pond
may very well dart
still though
i think it makes sense to put this guy
right here
it's a nice home
at some point i could try to break down
this structure
b4
yeah let's fall back now i'm in a
position to meet a4 with rook takes
this rook is a little clumsy strictly
defensive
i'm not really for seeing a way to win
this pawn
the king is
the one thing white has gone for him is
the activity of the king
it's a really useful square on d3
i should be playing on the side where
well
i still think i should be poking around
here on the queen side
if it's a strictly uh king and pawn
ending i believe it's winning
i have this idea
g4 forces through an outside pass pawn
that's worth noting this particular
configuration pawn here here and here
eventually g4 hits these guys can't do
much but
await
uh
a uh a past
black h-pawn
no so i should maybe keep that in mind
there
i guess we'll start with this
see first how white
tries to defend
put both rooks on
okay
and let's start with this
try this one
um
can my king do something better
i may i may have to
exchange one rook
in order for
in order for what
in order for me to better realize
my advantage
um
i don't know
i could i could put my king on d5 it's
i think it's pretty well secure there i
have to worry about
rook e5 one day
bishop has that covered
so we'll see it's tough to recommend a
move
team let's start with this one
maybe looking for this maneuver
i don't know
i mean i i could have
got exchange a rook forced a rook
exchange if i wanted to
but i think i think if i really want a
rook exchange i could manage to do that
in several ways
okay there is a pin here
uh i wonder if i can make use of that
this might be a moment for me to
transition
towards the king side
i'm gonna do that
i'm gonna pivot
here i am on the bishop
and uh now now
you know rook f5 or rook h5
the bishop could be defended but
this this rook here then then all of a
sudden maybe i
maybe i'm close to tracking down
the c3 pawn
evening out on the clock now
okay
okay that bishop is a little bit stuck i
could
i could shift gears
and say well now you're not around to
defend that guy
how to approach
it i think this is the way that this
seems just
way too good a square to not go to in my
rook
it has an influence on both
sides of the board
paves the way to kick the bishop
to this square and then maybe that and
then this
i i feel like i should be close to
winning a pawn
yeah i think i'm really close to winning
a pawn now all right let's start with
this one
i have to go here
i'm going to be winning a pawn shortly
uh no
no crazy pawn breaks for white
these are the two main ones i should be
i guess if there's a pawn moved i'd be
looking at
be this one since it hits harder
but
not really seeing
a move
all right
start with this
let's grab the pawn
here it's gonna be me
all right
um i was thinking about defending the
pawn but let's look forward
let me go with
remove this guy
i could try this
i guess i could go for that
seems really long-winded but
i do win the bishop they have to stir up
trouble somehow
or maybe maybe instead of hunting the
bishop i should say he's stuck good
enough let's keep this king around in
case something opens up on the b file
and let's get this guy back in
back in the ball game i don't know
uh trying to activate this rook drops
not only a pawn but may
may allow me
to to get a mate
e2 and d2 squares
this king king is no longer as
comfortable as i thought earlier
yeah going going to e4 did uh
did allow for this okay so i guess now
that's the plan
okay i i should probably go on the
offensive here
let's start with this one threatening
upon
yeah what do i do if the record's there
okay well
oh let's do it like this
here
i'm just repeating
through it goes back i'm going to try to
go to c4 putting pressure
on the file
see they're ready to exchange rook and
then
gobble up my my king side pawns
king already has a responsibility so
i guess i could save the pawns
let's put the king up here
i guess i could save the pawns if
this guy is exchanged for one of the one
of the rooks i could play here and if
this is
targeted i could play g5 my bishop is
useful
rook there
let's go here
so now trying to open stuff up like this
and then rook to h8 i have a rook h1 i
have rook h2
let's see
still only up a pond but i
like all my pieces
not but
i'm up upon
then i have good pieces
all right let's go for this
let's go for this
looking for this
maybe looking for this maneuver and made
on this square
ready take towards the center oh i'm
also seeing that
rook rick h7 opens up
but uh this is also super tempting
i think i'll go to just win the bishop
that was
didn't see it until
until the hval opened up
all right let's put the pawn in a pin
try for this still
the rooks really just never got
activated
i guess here
stop rook there
enable rook h2
a lot of ways to do it now
maintain two if the king goes here
let's still stick this bishop right here
trying to swipe the uh the bishop there
and then take my rook
oh i'm gonna get this one under 10
seconds here
there my opponent resigned
all right i have officially unplugged my
mouse
i think it should be good to go for the
remainder
of this tournament
playing against the legendary one
we're gonna get a move
mickey blue eyes is in first with 35
all right
i don't think my mouse will be
kind of stuttering like it was earlier
all right i went with this one because i
didn't want to even see the creation of
a duo
all right speaking of duos
how come how concerned am i about a
bishop getting to b4
i'll just cut it out
this is perfectly fine
bishop b4 bishop d7
all right
um
i could also consider a quick fiance
yeah
let's still keep my options open
with uh what door exactly i'm going to
open for my light square
bishop i think now i have to make that
decision or i should
do i want to put this guy out and about
i can maybe think a bit more about this
now with the bishop on this square
it could take a bit more time for black
to have a
major piece around supporting this e5
advance
here this this this
this kind of stuff maybe knight d7 and
then e5 will hit
and get a tempo how do i want to play
this
all right all right just go with the
fiance and not yet make a commitment
with my dark square bishop
or still maybe none of the above
queen c2 is also running through my mind
yeah let's go queen c2
how to describe that in one word i'm
thinking flexible i'm thinking
flexibility
okay well that move
seems to be a sign that black wants to
play d5
all right
so now the question is where's this
what's this guy going to do if this
isn't a
a thing anymore all right let's put this
guy here and i'm just going to go with a
standard
bishop outside the chain approach
i would really love to see this move
because it weakens this square there we
go
so i'm there in time to defend i have a
nice grip over e5
and i see a
healthy way forward
bishop here my maneuver my knight to f4
and then d3
my opponent may be angling for
some quick g5
to be careful about that
let me play h3
i'm anticipating some
some strike against my bishop i like
having this square
also
this could be seen as an aggressive move
come to think of it
yeah
aggressive in what way
let's start with this
aggressive in that g4 maybe
may have been an idea
wouldn't be able to take twice i'd have
a quick mate
all right let's put this bishop here
rather than e2
because i want this square open for my
knight
to transfer towards the king side
all right well
this pawn on the pawn on d5 was propped
up
with c6 and now there's
there's nothing being propped up anymore
black has given that guy up
okay
so now i'm thinking a little bit
different about where i want to go with
my bishop
this time it's this square
how quick things change
and the reason in this case is i don't
i want to eventually challenge the
bishop
yeah let's do this straight away i want
to get these moves in fast
maybe i was too fast
could this move still be played
since this pond's unprotected
okay forget about that
i could have gotten a little wild i
think queenside castles
might have been my reply
let's start with this
keep the diagonal open improve my bishop
night there so now
i may want to take right now
um but why
i feel like i'll have the better bishop
for
the long term
i don't see any reason to chop the
knight right now so
i'm not gonna do it
it'd be different if black was already
threatening this one
but
that would hang the b5 pawn
so maybe only after
this pawn is secure while i think about
this and then that way this pawn is
fixed on a light square and this guy
finds it difficult to do anything
exciting
i guess i'll go with
this rook
i'm expecting that this move will hit
and i don't think i want to take
i want to move here and have this still
secure
all right so now this may be nearby so i
think now i'm going to go ahead and chop
big decision here
okay so this guy is definitely
stuck how can i make forward progress
here
it's not easy
maybe
let's get this guy somewhere else
yeah let's get this guy somewhere else
i wonder if this would be a good idea
then try to get a rook here
fast gonna try for that looks
bizarre
but
these uh
these oddball structures i guess um
are available
when you have the better bishop
the thing is is when you
do the quick assessment of
the uh
the e5 the holes in the position well
i'm sorry these two squares this one
could be controlled
and this one cannot
i can control this one
with a bishop and black can't control
e5
also i mean this isn't even a hole i
have f3
all right let's begin with this
black has a little space
i i'm playing here anticipating
some queen d6 move
all right let's get this guy here
oh you know what i could have maybe
played instead
bishop here
control that pivot square
and then maybe both brooks are
maintained all right let's do this still
so a try right now for black maybe to
play rookie for
no okay
and give up the exchange straighten out
the structure and then try and
i don't know
um right now it's
i feel like i'm playing for two results
i mean there's also the time factor but
all right
i think we begin with this one for sure
you could try to circle in it's not it's
not too
far-fetched really to start thinking
about a queen or a king
walk to the c5 square
when the queens are exchanged
i didn't even see that that was a move
not too concerned about it i have my
base points covered
um
do i want to play here
i don't want my bishop to end up getting
stuck i don't know let's go to a safe
it's going to be kind of tricky to
challenge my dark square bishop or my
dark square bishop my dark squared rook
it's going to be tough to challenge this
guy
or uh
really i should be saying it as it's
going to be tough to try and take back
over control of the only open file
so this is a really nice positive
for white
controlling the e-file
good thing about these moves driving the
queen away
or just kind of be okay
with the queen there
let's go for this
gearing up for
rook there
queen here
can i work some magic is there some
tactic
that will tip in my favor with just
these through
the these three
playing within uh the structure
i wonder
well if i begin with this
and the bishop moves and then queen here
the rook has to go here
and the bishop knifes in let's start
with this
feels healthy
wasn't really doing a whole lot
on e5
oh
so what's the story with that bishop
officially cornered
i figured this was the way
oh i'm seeing a winning sequence
black has to play this one
i have an idea here here let's say this
move then i have this
a rook move and then the check
oh they missed that i'm on this square
oh
okay it happens
i think it was busted anyhow for black
there
not sure
another thought that ran through my mind
is uh black may be trying for c5 to
liberate the bishop it would cost a pawn
but there'd be a
past deep on
i don't think it would have posed a
great danger to me but
a great danger to me but i think it may
have been worth a try
to stir up some trouble
in some way
35 minutes left we get one more game in
for sure
kolka one
we've played before
getting berserked i'm not berserking
back i just want to play some
slow game
all right we're we're entering a similar
structure
let's focus on the light square
that one
yeah we do we might just have a
a similar structure
so what's the plan i mean i could i'm
already seeing that
i
could have a good knight versus bad
bishop
position
um
i could definitely get a bishop for
night exchange
put a knight here exchange nights
and this guy could
get to e4
let me just think through this here
how do i want to approach this
it's not really necessary to go in for
the bishop for knight exchange
and after this and then this
if i take straight away i may have to
deal with the
bishop being a bit of a pain on the a3
to f8 diagonal
and this knight isn't so great anyhow
where it's positioned i i like that the
c pawn is obstructed
i don't have to worry about a quick
strike against my center
pawn still home i don't have to worry
about the queen drifting towards the
queen side
well though i am seeing this this
take bishop takes when i play here
i'm turning clean here
all right i guess i'll
i guess i'll go for bishop b4 maybe
maybe i don't take the knight straight
away
i could also consider connecting knights
instead of bishop d2
maybe i castle first
or do i get on with uh moving my knight
i guess i'll castle
i believe i have a healthy pick
and let's put this guy here i'm not
concerned about tricks against my
unprotected bishop
here i could take the bishop straight
away or take on d5 straight away
is white gearing up for
[Music]
queenside castles
feels that way
maybe take
take and then here
restricting the bishop
i'm gonna go for that
i'll initiate the exchange and now work
on
making sure the bishop isn't able to
activate i want to keep my opponent's
pieces on their side of the board
so at some point i could create some
tension
with a4 i could even consider doing that
right now
the cost of allowing the bishop to get
on this diagonal
i think i want to begin with this though
in almost all cases and let's let's do
this move right now
i may be looking to drive that bishop
away or chop in a timely way so now
there's an additional light square
that's just lit up
so i could get at this guy here
both knights are super duper menacing
uh i think i should go for this
uh
if this pawn isn't able to get to c4
is it really even a pawn
what i'm doing here is is just working
in on the on the light squares
it's not really a whole lot
all i can do about it
i guess i want to be a little careful
here
well i could still jump in right now
why was i saying i need to be a little
bit careful
this move right here i don't want to
take i want to be in a spot to flush the
knight back but i was on the bishop
there
so let's put this guy here
oh no no no let's cut out 95
first
yeah let's cut out 95 first
so now
white wants to challenge has to
challenge with knight d2
maybe just over emphasize the light
square control play b5 here
okay and then here we go
a night exchange
which night to take which one which
night do i want to keep
i'll go with this one
i'm going to try and converge here
also yeah i think yeah this is the
better night
so let's go here
i may even consider uh king walk so now
so now this rook has responsibility
something has the responsibility
i think it's
i think it's always going to be
inconvenient for white to try and defend
this guy
so i mean i have some
some maneuver like this
i'm gonna i'm gonna go for it
maybe
maybe there's a
a trick white falls for at some stage
there is a way to open up the king side
with the g5 break
but before doing that i have the time to
go for this
walk towards the
walk towards the queen side
i could have maybe considered that but i
wanted to cut out this one you know the
bishop's hanging
this is going to be a really tall task
ahead there for
team white
just up a piece now
queen h4 kg7
now we just crash through straight away
i guess you could do it straight away
not guess i know here being up the piece
all right
i don't care about going pawn hunting
may end up getting a similar mate
as in the last game
made on g2 queen h4
h5 instead of the king over
here's another one
okay i'm not getting to that uh
not getting to the second rank so easily
no rush here
all right what's the story
what is the story i think i want to
offer a queen exchange
i don't want to take here and have to
deal with this
i don't know it's welcome mcqueen
exchange
yeah let's just welcome a queen exchange
that's the one of the weaknesses of the
last move
okay
i don't care if these guys end up ugly
double isolated pawns
let me just take
no entry points
i don't care about this guy
let's give the check first
uh i could take this guy
let's do it no stalemates to worry about
and i want this guy
this is this rook should really never
end up seeing my side of the board
just cover my
cover my bases
we should be having main three
okay
it's a delicate position
make that early weakness on e4
provide some really useful information
to team black
able to easily deploy the the pieces and
point at that weak square
that have
ended up translating into a super strong
knight versus a bad bishop
it paved the way for that
all right venda
venda gambit
first time playing
this player
this should be the last game counting
for the tournament
another
exchange carro
not c4 though
yet could still be played
okay it seems much more tame
gonna
secure the bishop no
i don't know if i really gain a whole
lot playing knight b4
and this is perfectly fine bishop g4
i'll just play bishop g4
you know
i mean this check bishop d7
let's just
go like this
oh what am i
i should have
once more here
thinking too too much about the standard
moves i could have captured the knight
won the pawn
it should still be very good for me
though
a very good structure
rook activity i may not need the castle
but i should have been winning upon
there
played a little too fast
all right well this was my first thought
but maybe i could take a timeout and say
i don't want to see your bishop get to
f4 so easily
maybe
maybe we could try that
maybe i wonder if some knight move here
if i was threatening to take and then do
something on h2
not quite mate
there let's stop this uh
this isn't a reliable defender
there was
this and then this has a threat i'm not
concerned about this one i could go here
still stop bishop f4
and then next look to drive the night
away
so
i have to be careful here even this
night move and then this move
maybe now i
castle or no i don't i don't want a
queenside castle
i thought we defend like this
that way this guy isn't pinned
all right
queenside castle now
or stop knight b5 altogether
let me stop knight b5
yeah let me cut this one out also i'm
prepared to
recapture with my g-pawn
and just as in game
once i want one of my games
from earlier because of this pin
and setting up bishop f4 i imagine
queen side castle here
not sure exactly how to improve
can you have eight maybe i don't know if
i want to go queen side
feels a little weird but i i'm going to
do it i i feel like he's safer here
same sides not quite castles
all right so now i could play bishop d6
i figured bishop f4 was going to be
played
right away
i'm out of
i'm off the e file
white maybe going for this maneuver
i could be considering this maneuver too
maybe i should have
i don't know
maybe now that i have a little bit more
control over e5
i feel more comfortable with the night
maneuver
also if this guy moves this guy moves
this guy moves maybe this guy moves no i
could take on e5
anyhow these guys are currently fighting
against one another these guys are
fighting against one another
competing for
these two
and these two
well percent sign percent nights
all right
what's the plan
don't think there's any tricks there
okay
half open file
i would really like to see this capture
because then i have a nice square for my
king
ooh
okay
this bishop is restricted
is there some accident happening here
soon
then queen taking here
gearing up for this move maybe
if i move this knight threatening this
how's that defended
my knight is also defending my rook in
case of some skewer if i end up taking
here
maybe i play knight here
yeah i think i'm gonna do that
you in here a little copycat copycat
nights
queen there what's the story
what's that move doing oh okay you're
threatening this guy
noted
oh
interesting
i didn't see that move
wow
i have to do something really awkward
wow there's some nice tricks here for
white there there there there
that falls
that being some trouble here
wow
okay
also this there's this and then this
huh totally missed that move
hmm
uh i am kind of stuck here
wow knight h4 queen f3
very slick
very slick
hmm
i gotta make a move so this i guess i'm
gonna try this one
i don't know i feel i'm feeling busted
that one really caught me off guard
strong move
maybe king f8 wasn't so great
maybe i should have uh castle queenside
and that one crushed my time
spent way too much there
but
in a tough spot
credit to my opponent's queen f3 move
maybe
i have a trick one day against a3 to get
a pawn back
mike goes forward with the rook
rook takes e6 move
or it takes e6
rick takes here i believe one of these
two
is available
only then the recapture
because if this this and then here then
i take
but even then there's something
are you going with it
like this
i don't have really much choice
interesting
so now the night's ready to go here
wow
very nice
all right i think i have to try this one
tough tough tough i don't think i could
afford uh night capture's pawn here it's
killer so i have to
oh i mean this is working too i was
thinking i could go here but then this
falls
all right
save the rook
this one is gonzo
to block with the rook clean here down
three pawns soon to be a fourth
very nice
more than that
uh yeah i don't have anything it's one
check
not good enough
check
if the king goes here i get me king g1
though
i'm in a pin
threatening to get the queens off
a lot of ways to win it here from white
wow
queen f3
felt difficult and i think it was
difficult
unusual
knight h4 very unusual
felt the pressure
okay
look here the queens come off
uh
if i play
if i play here there's knight here
screen check as well
rook check probably works
and we're in a spot where
i guess
try and find the move that doesn't win
for white that's the that's the hard
part
[Music]
no hope
we'll get one more game in it won't
count for the tournament
i'll make sure to resign
before i think what
as long as there's four minutes or more
in the tournament
you'll still get paired up
get one more game in there
i don't know here
i'm only down five pawns and a knight
oh man
look here looking for this
look
here i take here there's a check and
then this
i have f2 that'd be way to lose
forgetting about the pressure on f2
checkarony
all right let's go here
this within this
i'm on the night
queen's defending the pawn
consolidating moves are fine knight e3
everything's defended
knight f5
nearby
that'll be a killer
how'd i get rid of that knight
here here there's a check i go in the
corner maybe i get at this point
i don't know try this
ready for a check now
let's go here if i go to this file it's
going to be a problem there's still
going to be a problem check here another
check
here another check here
only move
only move
there could go here now
i don't have the pressure on f2
final move rookie one and i'm gonzo
another check
oh if i go here there's night there
so
i guess here
let's check here
all right i think now is the time
to throw on the towel
main two
one two
depending on where my king goes or rook
here coming up
that's a good start
or night move probably wins too
that's gonna do it
well done
all right let's get one more game in
yeah how could well i could have been
more
attentive in the early going and won
that d-pawn
that certainly would have helped
too fixated on the
the usual stuff
of uh h3 oh i don't take a pinned piece
let me maintain the pin
okay
cost me
well it's not to say i was gonna go
ahead and win but
be nice to win a pawn in the opening
if you can
alright this one i'm pretty sure is
going to be the final one
for this tournament that will not count
so how many games two three four five
six
seven games in
any time now
okay
let's go
with
b3
why not
all right now let's let's see if i could
win a pawn early
alright that is a different
f6 huh
d5 straight away
c4 stop the duo
let's go with c4 first
i would okay still playing that
i was going to say i'd like to play d4
and after capture
i think i would
i would like to recapture with a knight
okay well i played c4 to break up a duo
if it arrived on board
so let's do it
develop the knight straight away
i guess so let's get this tempo
queen
there
and let's put this guy here
not too concerned about e4 feels like
black would be overextended going for
that i have a
forward move myself
attacking the queen uh
i think now is the time to play d5 uh d4
um bishop b4 shouldn't be too much of a
bother so
d4 it is
that one
i don't have a great square for my
knight
so let's go here first and then we have
d4
for the knight
queen also has to go to a weird square i
think
and still defend this guy
so here this guy's not too happy
or there
but now i get to move
through a punch
all right
queen has officially found
a home
let's go here
light square bishop
bishop's eyes are opened queen's eyes
are opened
not available on h5 just yet
okay but now
i could consider maybe flicking in queen
h5
this would
is it worthwhile to provoke g6 is a
question
not so sure
i think what i want to play is a4
why no
why of all moves a4 because i want this
without this
eventually i want to move
this guy
let's go here
or or this guy
i want to challenge this strong
strong queen
maybe i do well not to castle so soon
let's let's retreat with this guy
i'm defending this enough and now this
as well on d5 it was uh it was under
attack because my knight and c3 is
pinned
so if i just castled instead of this
knight move knight g4 is irritating
if i play h3 i have to be a bit careful
here cause
isn't um
isn't there going to be something
happening here soon i guess i can
consider getting rid of the pawn right
now
landing a discovered check with d6 now
that the king is there
do i want to do that
queen d4 or d6
what's running through my mind
hmm
i don't know that i want to give up my
my pawn just yet
i feel like i could interact with this
guy
pretty well
knight d4
into e6
knight f4 into e6
i was black when i play this okay
initiates the exchange i thought maybe
even the bishop falling back looking to
get on a
pivot on e5 rather than on b4
okay now bishop there
so this cuts out any pawn advance
how does how does black finish
development
let me begin with this one
i'm thinking more about castling queen
side
so if knight d7 there's a an issue on
this square i could
i could maybe consider
some attack against the king even though
the queens are off still major pieces
queenside castle g4 is the beginning of
some
line opening
and this diagonal has opened up some
i i think i want to go queen side i'm
gonna go i'm gonna try for queen side i
think
um yeah
yeah let's go queenside
it's still i think a little bit annoying
if my knight gets here maybe not this
guy is super good
maybe not
when i just say this guy's super good
that guy is super good
try and get rid of him
how do i do that
not easy
all right how about this
retreat
and i may just be all right with
allowing the knight to take my
bishop yeah
i guess
these are pretty strong i would say that
this guy right here
is a best piece
opponent is playing with the bishop pair
but that should be short-lived with
these guys in tension
tough to duck that
bishop b5 i could take the rook
the tournament is officially over
still some game left
i have some space black has some space
a healthy move from here is king b2
uh another healthy move may be c4
my favorite piece in this position is
this guy
think it's my best piece
i play v6
b6
some move like b5 available
here b5
i could take on poisson but chop
chop chop chop chop
there
my knight falls back i am up a pawn
could be a little scary for me
maybe i begin with improving my king a
hair
king c2
still there might be something with the
rook entering on a2
i guess king here
but then i could end up in some pin
i would like to get these two moves in
but i think c5 is is met with b5 and
some c6 is met with b4
not easy
maybe i enter some variation with this
pawn has picked up
maybe
let's see if black goes for b5
oh you know what i could maybe try after
b5 maybe i play here
and a capture then i get to the seventh
rank okay not going for that
maybe a maybe this move right now
to be careful can't move this night
skewer town
there
now this
let's try it
black could attack it three times oh my
goodness i missed that that was even a
move
why am i missing that move man
do i have to play here
knight takes pawn pawn takes pawn
this knight is going to get here one way
or the other another knight is returning
here
down on the clock as well
night there night there
all right let's try and mix it up
maybe if i end up losing a pawn
um
oh that one
did not expect that so i feel like even
some exchange sacrifice
i can be okay with this pawn now
connected and passed
so taking a night here in other words
let's start with this
i'm going to dive in straight away
okay
go with this one
i wouldn't i would like to have both
minor pieces off if i can
right here this one
oh my goodness this is it now
alright here comes the exchange sack
get this guy in the ball game
try not to open it try not to allow my
opponent to open
lines
so this this
this maybe this or this yeah let's try
and keep it closed
i have two connected passers oh
so
yeah let me let me try to do this one
control this square and push this guy
that's the plan given a move i think
i'll play f3
my king is uh pretty pretty active
i feel like a
maybe to maybe be tipping in my
favor with the evaluation i'm not sure
that move is bothersome yeah
i'm gonna say
one step is best
if i go two i'm maybe asking for more
pawn moves that attempt to open up the
position at the same time
i have to be tethered to the defense of
h3 right now but
maybe that'll be short-lived i think
posting these nights on dark squares you
know this is another idea i could try to
win this pawn
let's start with this one around the
bishop
oh
also it can't go back i could take
if i could draw an arrow and then follow
up with the fork so the
yeah so i could get the exchange back
and i should and then i'm going to be up
a pawn and have
a completely winning position
really really feels like i'm i'm going
to be up two pawns
soon
and i think this because
why
this guy controls these two
these two offset
these guys all offset
and these are the two extra pawns
connected and passed not quite connected
what's
the simple
what's the correct technique here
i can begin by putting
the correct technique is to move
faster
wow
let's start with that
and then here here here and then collect
this pawn
that's the
way to go like that pressure here first
oh this move
um
i think i still allow it
if a file opens up in this in this case
uh
like i try to get to the a file
h file excuse me so
there there there
let's take
here
if i went here this one is going to
track down my pawn i may have some
some pawn racing fast
let's start with this
now let's start with this
now let's start with this maybe i lose
this pawn but i want to get these two
oh you're going with that one so now i
could get this file
and i'm ready to challenge the king no
stalemates to worry about
it always move this guy
so now the threat is here and then
winning the rook the fork
time really shouldn't be an issue at
this stage
it's much more clear
the minor pieces were still around
problems
tricky nights
and it's getting mated
i have to go here
peridot oh that's not even helping it's
a main two
the main three
after the king went here
and opponent resigned okay
got some good drops in there
420
tough uh
tough final opponent there that counted
for the tournament venda venda gambit
good game
that knight h4 queen f3
interesting maneuver
didn't really expect that kind of
pressure on my king side and the tactics
seem to
be working well for
form
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video it's been a while
since i posted a rapid event
yeah i hope you found it
uh useful
that's all for now take care bye
you